believe in what you're going to do and
and and don't read anything that's
negative I find that whenever I don't
follow my instinct that's when things
can go wrong and I really felt that
number one we found a spot in New York
that was budget-friendly it's never easy
to find a great team although a team
makes all the difference it's really
about just figuring out the balance I'm
actually a very shy person so to do PR
and be shy is a challenge with social
media transparency is super important
and being authentic every decision we
make is thinking about how it will
affect our company five and ten years
from now even if you don't start out in
the perfect job whatever you do is going
to shape and enrich your perspective
timing perseverance and ten years of
really hard work will eventually make
you look like an overnight success she's
an American fashion designer
businesswoman and philanthropist she's
the chairman CEO and designer of Tory
Burch LLC she has an estimated net worth
of 1 billion dollars she's Tory Burch
and here her top 10 rules for success
when I started the company my parents
said thicken your skin this is gonna be
if it takes off it's gonna be hard at
times and you're gonna have to listen or
not listen to the negativity and think
of it as noise and really just believe
in what you're going to do and and and
don't read anything that's negative and
and and just believe in yourself how do
you know specifically for your company
when it's right to enter a market how do
you personally make that decision well I
think it's right when you're right and I
think that it's it's when I when I talk
to entrepreneurs I always say when you
enter the market make sure you have a
unique concept and idea and I always
look at the market and if you're missing
something that's a pretty good judge of
it and I think it's about instinct and I
find that whenever I don't follow my
instinct that's when things can go wrong
but I think
it's listen when 2011 happened I knew
that wasn't the right time so I think
you have to really have a very focused
business plan and you have to really
believe in it and be passionate about it
but I think there's never really a wrong
time it's all about you and what you're
ready for opening a store on your first
day that you launch a brand is a huge
risk why did you choose just well I was
warned against it over and over again
and and I really felt that number one we
found a spot in New York that was
budget-friendly
and it was basically it was it was very
little money and we felt or I felt that
I wanted to create an environment and
retail at the time was minimalist it was
very stark and clean and we thought it'd
be interesting to be inspired by David I
was very inspired by David Hicks in the
beginning and this idea of coming into a
welcoming and warm environment having
couches for boyfriends or husbands or
children and and making it accessible
and friendly but also interesting and so
it was a way to show who we were
immediately when you walked in and it
was everything we launched with I think
12 categories which also people thought
was ridiculous and it was a lot of going
to China I set up an office from the
beginning and convincing factories to
work with us and taking a shot on us
because making twenty and fifty pieces
of something was essentially losing
money for them so when when we ended up
getting that done this store was the
best place to really house that and show
it and speak to our customer Larry I
would say it's never easy to find a
great team although a team makes all the
difference and I I've never been one I
guess I've always been one to look for
people that I think are more talented
than me and I've never been one to be
scared of that and I think that's a very
good thing to remember as you start to
work because if you surround yourself
with stellar people it just it makes
things possible and that's what I've
done as my whole career I've surrounded
myself with people that I think are
brilliant
well I always
to test my boys and say okay I can be a
stay-at-home mom what do you think
they're like no no no we don't want that
so I think that's kind of funny in a way
but I think my boys know they're my
first priority and I think it's about
how being a mother to me is the gift of
the world to me and but also being able
to have a company like this as well so I
think it's really about just figuring
out the balance and it's always gonna be
a balance in my opinion having it all
and what all these people are talking
about now is a very individual question
I don't think that having it all means
everything to the same person so you
have to figure out what having it all is
for you I certainly had to give certain
things up things that I didn't mind
giving up but my family and my work came
first and that's sort of finding that
balance but I also looked at PR
differently when I was doing PR because
I was I'm actually a very shy person so
to do PR and be shy is a challenge so I
had to think creatively it really on
some levels is what has helped build our
business PR marketing and social media
we've never advertised we didn't have
the budget but we've never advertised
until our first ad this month or the
last month of is Estee Lauder but I
think it's really about nuance and and
that was what I learned it's sort of how
to create a story and embrace
storytelling we were talking about it a
little earlier and I think a story there
there is a class that I was just telling
him run about the power storytelling at
Stanford and it's extraordinary when you
look at business and and the way story
has really affected and helped build
businesses and really that's where PR
comes in and marketing and social media
now the last six or so years I think you
might agree that we learn more from our
failures than our successes well there's
been so many challenges that we've had
and I think I think you know one thing I
talked to my team a lot about is during
those challenges you have to really
be a leader and you have to lead with
conviction so the toughest times which
I've been through many I mean I could
just say one time we were changing
systems and we didn't back up anything
properly it was maybe six years ago it
was a huge mistake so it was when social
media was really taking off we're just
starting Twitter and everything but it
was maybe a six month problem and we had
to make the decision to be authentic and
really talk about it with our customer
and or not and the great thing is with
with social media transparency is super
important and being authentic and just
in general that's how our companies set
up but to have to so we we decided to do
that it was it took us maybe eight
months to get out of a really bad place
of going to New Jersey packing up packs
of boxes ourselves and you want everyone
on our team I'm sure some people over
there including myself on Sunday nights
at 2:00 in the morning would be packing
and shipping boxes and we had no
visibility so that was a perfect but
that's that we learned from it we now
have really good systems going in
working with sa P which is a lot of fun
and so there's been so many but but I
think it's really learning from the
problems and mistakes it's really the
telling part it's how you go forward how
do you a manage that kind of growth and
B do it in a way that still kind of
keeps your brand interesting so it's not
ubiquitous yeah and and that's when you
think of the hundred and eleven stores
it's in 55 countries so really that's I
think we're very careful about being
everywhere and that's really important
and I think we we are interested in
really having an authentic relationship
with our customer and it's never about
just growth for growth's sake we always
look at who's buying e-commerce and
where they're from we look at who's in
our stores who's in our Miami stores
that's why we started to open stores in
Brazil is that we start to really feel
when
there's a need in different countries
and that's that's where we are we just
recently signed Paris which is really
exciting and it's an American designer
we wanted to treat Paris very carefully
because you don't want to just go in
with the big opening and we wanted to
learn the market and see what would
resonate there so each place we go we
want to be respectful we want to learn
the cultures and see really understand
the the women that are there and the
Middle East is a great market for us and
so I'm not sure if I'm answering your
question but I think it's I think it's
very strategic growth and it's obviously
been so enormous but it really has been
restrained and if we could be much
bigger and we're not interested we're
very careful about where we open and
adjacencies and and we really want to
protect the integrity of the brand of
every decision we make as is thinking
about how it will affect our company
five and 10 years from now even if you
don't start out in the perfect job
whatever you do is going to shape and
enrich your perspective pay attention
and be open to the experience and you
will always take something away from it
and that is something that each job that
I had it was a building block to finding
my passion being an entrepreneur isn't
just a job title it isn't just about
starting a company it's about a state of
mind it's about seeing connections
others can't seizing opportunities
others won't and forging new directions
that others haven't
it's about being entrepreneurial
wherever you are and in whatever you do
it's about having the courage to give in
to a passion for an idea that makes your
heart race and if it doesn't scare you
the idea isn't big enough here's what
I've learned we may live in an age of
instant messaging instant gratification
and Instagram but there is no way to
short-circuit the path to success it
takes hard work tenacity and a lot of
patience there are many things you can
do overnight you can write a decent
paper
or you can put finishing touches on a
fashion show I hear you can't even have
a pretty good time at Rogers pub but
there is no such thing as an overnight
success it is a myth that glosses over
what being an entrepreneur is all about
as biz Don one of the founders of
Twitter's put it timing perseverance and
ten years of really hard work will
eventually make you look like an
overnight success thank you so much for
watching I made this video because your
Varnum Ilana [ __ ] asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do
I'd also love to know which of the top
ten rules which of the clips hit you the
hardest is gonna have the biggest impact
on you leave it in the comments below
and I'll join in the discussion and my
personal goal on the channel is to get
to a million subscribers so anything you
can think of to share the video tell
friends about it tweet it out I'd really
deeply appreciate it thank you so much
for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon